معنا خبير زلازل من انطاكيا
السيد عدنان عدنان المبيض ما هي المعلومات
التي لديكم حتى الان
يعطيكم العافيه
ضربت هزه زلزاليه شدتها سته فاصله اربعه
مركز هاتاي طبعا
احنا موجودين حاليا مرسين شعر الاهالي
بضياء
طبعا الحمد لله
يعني
الاضرار بالنسبه للمنطقه هون ما موجود ما
في شيء ان شاء الله
الشيء اللي نحن يعني عم نقول انه كانه صار
انتقال مركز الزياده الزلازل لمنطقه ثانيه
على الفالق نفسه الفالق الاناضولي المركز
حاليا تغير من مركز لانطاكيا
هذا اللي هلا حاليا
موجوده الموجود المعلومات في انه المركز
حاليا بينطاقها شده 6.4
النطاق نطاق التاثير نطاق
واسع يعني
حلب
عنتاب وصولا الى مرسين ومسمى الرجوع الى
المنطقه التاثير منطقه كبيره وبالتالي ليس
لا يعتبر هذا من الهزات الارتداديه متبادل
زلزال يعني تولد زلزال
بحد ذاته نعم